again another can't then those who can
hear the problem haha so it's the first
time that I could set up doing the Q&A
with the the computer that I had in my
other house and the and the microphone
so starting to get everything in place
things are coming in place so a little
bit of news may has been in a crazy
month I had set up me as a as a crazy
month because because I didn't want to
travel during Lent and so cuz I didn't
want to travel during Lent i I had a
cousin traveling during Lent is this
year I wanted to be a bit stricter in
terms of the fast terms the fasting and
I knew that if I traveled in Lent it's
just impossible it's totally impossible
to fast it and so I really try not to
travel during Lent which means that I
had put all my traveling right after
pasca like right after Easter
I had three things three official trips
that I had to do in May and then I also
had a family thing that I needed to do
in May and so yeah so it's been it's
been pretty crazy I was in Seattle with
father Stephen Freeman doing a doing
some talk there it was that was amazing
it was so much fun
the Shane and Shawn who organized it
they've been supporting me for a long
time and they're just they're just
awesome so I had so much fun with then
we had cigars and and I stayed at chains
house it was a lot it was just great and
fun being with father Stephen there's
something about a father Stephen
Freeman's
the way he speaks about things and the
way he really emphasizes the ontological
transformation in his Christian
understanding
I just think jives so well with what I'm
doing so he was talking about say mac at
saint gregory of nyssa and then in my
talk I ended up talking about st.
Gregory so those talks were
professionally recorded professionally
filmed and they should be out next week
I really I've been really pushing myself
a little more especially you know
because when I do the videos when I make
the videos
for YouTube I tried to go easy on a lot
of the you how to make things flow and
so I try to go easy on the references to
church history and the references of the
Church Fathers and I do it on purpose
because you know I I want what I'm doing
to be accessible to everybody which
sometimes I was led to the accusation
that I'm just pulling this stuff out of
my hat or that I am a union which is
something that has been coming back over
and over and so I thought when I go on
these more these trips where I'm invited
by churches or invited by more let's say
Church related groups then I maybe I'm
going to lay it on a little more in
terms of the references that I use and
so I've been I did an event in Seattle
and then I did an event in Louisiana
which I got back from yesterday at
midnight and both those both those
events I end up going into the church
fathers the first one into the hesychast
ik father's a lot and then the one in
Louisiana I really then are not breaking
down saying effort more and more because
I know some people have told me that
they've read the they've read the ends
of Paradise which I've suggested that
you all read but they're they don't
they're not getting what how can I say
this they're struggling to see what I'm
seeing in Saint Ephrem and so I
understand that because you know it's
not easy we're not used to thinking in
symbolic terms and so it's it's
sometimes it's difficult to but you can
perceive where it is that Saint Ephrem
is making connections that are helpful
for us and so I'm going to put those up
in the next few weeks all of those talks
are going to go up so for talks for
different talks and I'm probably also
going to do a some interpretations of
sin ephraim for the channel as well just
because yeah just because just to help
people to to know how to read the church
fathers and see the patterns that i'm
talking about so so that'll be happening
soon so so yeah so i'm actually i'm
happy to do this Q&A with you guys
because it makes me feel like something
that things are
are coming back into into order like you
know I did the Q&A with it like one day
or two days after the whole flood thing
happened I was my parents I was so sick
that night guys
you know when I finished the last Q&A um
I got up I got into the bead and the
adrenaline was really keeping me going
but then when I was finished I got up
and I shouted shaking like a leaf you
know when you're when you're sick and
you just have you know you just have all
this pain all over and so I'm just
shaking and shaking shaking all I can do
is to make it to the bed where I was
sleeping and just plop down and and pass
out so narrow it's better the things are
better we're in this house that we're
renting and and so so talking to guys
feels great I'm happy that this is
happening all right so let's go with the
questions all right
so in the let's start with the symbolic
world website so Jacob says something
I've struggled with this is Jacob Jacob
the fool as he is that he is known in
the comments jacob russell something
something i'm struggle with
understanding is what belief actually
entails it seems very limited to equated
to i know something exists scripture
indicates without looking closer at the
greek it means something closer to
leaning on or perhaps holding near does
this relate to the heart or center like
you are bringing or remembering who
Christ is in your inner secret place you
use it in an interesting way when
talking about evolution did it happen
sure do I believe in it no I don't
believe in it what's the peso and oh my
goodness a Jovian you heard it here
first he says with the petroleum way of
relating to this word yeah we need to
find a petroleum that's not good we need
to find a better way all right so I
think that the best way to understand
belief is trust
you know in the idea faith I think I
think faith is probably the best way we
talk about belief in that Creek in a
Christian manner and faith and faith is
trust you know and so what it is it's an
it's an attachment to something but it's
an attachment to something that you do
with your whole being you know it's like
if you ask me do I think you know do I
think that this bridge is going to hold
me when I walk out on it you know yes
but do will I do it if I do it is
because I trust I trust that the bridge
is going to hold on that's very
different so Trust is more is more it's
closer to your being and it also becomes
a motivation for action and so even when
they when when when James talks about
the idea that you know that there is no
faith without works like you know show
me show me your faith without words and
I'll show you my faith with words the
idea is that faith inevitably brings
about words because faith is trust and
it is and so it it didn't it exists in
the world of action it doesn't it exists
obviously in in the mental world as well
but it also exists in the world of
action it's not just belief in in an
abstract manner and so and so I think
that I think that that's the best way to
understand it and and like Jacob
suggested Trust is related to the things
that I've been talking about oh yeah I
guess you guys haven't heard me talking
about that yet because I'm gonna put
those talks up yeah but uh this notion
of memory and attention the idea of the
manners in which we are connected to the
heart to the center to the manner in
which we're connected to Christ and so
the the you know Trust is if you you
know if you trust something that you
lacked in you'll act in that in that
direction you will use it as a basis for
what you act and so you're totally right
when I said that when I talked about
this notion of evolution did it happen
sure if everything we know that's
exactly what I was referring
it was saying that I doesn't bother me
I'm not bothered by the ideas that
evolution that evolution talked about
you know but but I don't I don't it's
not a it's not that by which I base my
life on it's not not that on which I
thought that by which I believe er or I
don't act I never act in terms of
evolution you know the categories by
which that in for my actions are our
categories of love of communion of the
their human you know they're human how
can I say this yeah they're they're
phenomenological more than just thought
so alright hope that answers your
question
Jacob my next question is from David
Flores and I was really happy because
David came to this event in Shreveport
Louisiana and we had talked on the phone
a few times before but I was really
happy to get to meet him finally after
like two years of him kind of being
around supporting me and I've seen his
questions in the question period so that
was a lot of fun I was really happy to
meet you David I don't he's here in the
anyways he probably watches later he's
not here
so David says you mentioned in your
lecture that st. gregory of nyssa said
that christ was the serpent could you
talk more about this so he's talking
about the lecture that I did in
Shreveport I had noticed that in some
crucifixion images he does look a bit
serpentine so so first of all I first of
all the idea would be that I wrote an
article about that the article is called
the serpents of Orthodoxy I mean let me
actually put it down in the chat so you
guys can check it out later
I wrote this quite a while ago
in 2013 so that's a while ago no all
right so this is the link and it goes so
the idea is synced Lisa doesn't say that
does it say that Christ is the serpent
he says Christ became the serpent so
Christ became the serpent for us okay it
has to you know it's similar to the
notion that Christ became sin that
Christ trampled down death by death all
this idea that Christ you know I always
tell you guys that on the one hand it's
it's fine to see Christ at the center of
or the top of the hierarchy as the at
the center of the wheel all those images
are fine but we also need to understand
that Christ is also the totality of the
hierarchy he also covers the entire
thing from the highest to the lowest so
that's very different it's not different
because you you finally realize that in
fact that's what the center ends up
being ultimately everything is contained
in the center you know ultimately but
sometimes it's hard to see it whereas
Christ we really seen his story that he
travels from the highest to the lowest
and he actually joins them together
especially in the in the notion of the
cross the cross it's so hard to think
about because it's both at the top of a
hill you know it's this is this vertical
that meets the the horizontals with this
joining of heaven and earth but then
it's also a humiliation it's also a form
of death it's also a form of torture
it's also how we treat criminals how we
treat outsiders and Christ and Christ
you know instead that he is outside the
city of Jerusalem and on the Mount of
skulls but then you'll see traditions
that say that this mount of skulls is
the Garden of Eden that this mountain
that this this hill of the scroll is
also the place where Adam was buried or
sometimes literally talking now it's
that it's the place of Eden you know and
so joining all those extremes together
now in terms of the serpent I think
David you're totally right your
intuition that Christ looks like a
serpent on crosses I think is completely
right you know and I think that that is
done it's done very intuitively I'm not
sure it's done up
I was done on purpose but it I think I
was just a natural intuitive way that it
manifested itself one has to do with the
very very you know if you look at a
vertical vertical line with a with a
swerve around it you know like a dollar
sign or a damage of the medical image
you know they're fat pharmaceutical
image those images of a of a of a
vertical with a snake that goes up like
you see the garden the serpent in the
Garden of Eden I think that honestly I
think that that that geometric pattern
is is really really written on our
consciousness I think that it is it is
probably one of the most basic patterns
that we have in us that we notice you
know like we notice faces like we notice
crosses like we notice there are certain
structures that we see you know and they
they they're very satisfying to us
because they they they're very
primordial and I think that that that
image of a vertical with a serpent is
extremely primordial because I think it
is it is a way to represent everything
is that image no because it's basically
a vertical with a swerving so it's a
straight and a crooked has and it shows
you what the quickened does that it goes
out but it comes back so it's it so if
you see the serpent going like that you
know it's also a cycle you just don't
really don't you have to realize that
the fact that it goes out and he comes
back you can understand it as a cycle so
if you imagine that the serpent going
around the tree then you understand that
it's a cycle that it's like it's a
ladder but it's also a cycle so it's
like this ascending cycle or descending
cycle okay so I think that that's really
probably one of the most primordial
images now in terms of Christ becoming
the serpent to read the article you see
oh of many examples where I pointed that
but it's also it mostly you know has to
do with these images in the old
testament like the image of the the rod
which becomes the serpent in the case of
Moses the fact that when when Moses lets
go is rod he becomes a serpent and then
we
holds on to it it becomes a rod again
then it's also the image of the bronze
serpent where you have poisonous snakes
which are biting below and then taking
the image of those snakes and putting it
above deliberately becomes a healing
mechanism and so Christ even says that
he is like a bronze serpent he he
actually uses that analogy to talk to to
talk about himself until hopefully that
answers but if you're interested here's
the guys check out that article um
I don't write articles anymore I don't
have time but I used to write a lot if
you guys are you guys want to get more
similars especially more Christian
symbolism I have a whole I have dozens
and dozens of articles that I wrote you
know between 2012 and and 2016 I would
say or 2015 then you can find all right
so des brew asks would love to hear you
talk about the symbol of Melchizedek who
was is who was is he and how can we
understand his likeness to Christ
now keys attic is a very very strange
figure and there are many many
traditions which try to explain his role
in the story let's say there are some
traditions which say that Melchizedek is
Shem that he is the the son of Noah the
son of Noah who who who never died we
didn't die and so he was there all the
way up to Abraham and so because of that
he is without generation because he is
the first generation out of the out of
the ark there's some people who talk
about that there are other weird
traditions that I've seen then that I
don't even remember where they're from
but that mentioned how milky Zadok
you know is there from before the flood
that he hid he was in the Garden of Eden
you know how I tell you talking about
how Saint Ephrem in Senate from the
Syrian side either the garden is over
he was never touched by the flood that
the good that the flood came up to the
gates of the garden but that they never
never entered the garden so there's this
idea that Melchizedek was there in the
garden during the flood that he's a that
he's a figure from before the flood and
that's why he's also with our generation
and that's kind of just technical stuff
but if you think about those different
images you can you can understand maybe
what what they could mean but uh but but
the the idea that Christ is them as much
for Christians in the Epistle the
Hebrews is really where you get the
understanding of the importance of no
accuse attack is that Melchizedek seems
to represent a kind of pure spiritual
figure where he there's no reference to
him he is just this figure which comes
and who blesses and his blessing is
bread and wine and and it's interesting
you know because there's something about
that which is it's kind of like haha
bread and wine or this you know they're
the sacrifices of the of the the
agriculturalists and so the Hebrews were
pastoralist
and most of their sacrifices not all but
most of their sacrifices are animal
sacrifices
whereas Melchizedek brings the sacrifice
of bread and wine in some of you maybe
don't even know Melchizedek is and I'm
talking to you guys as if you do now
Kizer that appears in the Old Testament
at a moment where Abraham is shown as a
a warlord and an melt and Abraham helps
he defeats the the enemies I forget the
name of the tribe who defeats these
enemies and because of that he receives
the blessing of milk he's at
Melchizedek is a priest king he's a kid
who offers sacrifice and and he's very
mysterious it doesn't say much about him
but then in the Epistle the Hebrews you
know it suggested that no Pisa Dec has a
higher authority than Abraham because he
blesses Abraham and so it's like they
decide you that he is this higher figure
and you can see that he's an image of
Christ because he offers he's a king and
a priest which which only Christ is in
that sense if you look in the Old
Testament you never you know get kings
and priests they don't go together you
know there and there's a separate
separate two separate castes you know
there's a the priestly caste and a and a
royal caste and they don't mix and so
and in the time where for example
there's a story of King Uzziah who goes
into the temple and offer sacrifice and
because of that he he has leprosy
because he he he acted in sacrilege he
he tried to take for himself what was
above him kind of like Adam and Eve in
the garden
whereas Melchizedek seems to actually be
above that distinction above the
distinction of earthly you know
political power and spiritual power and
so he joins them together just like cry
joins them together and he also offers
bread and wine which is that which is
this this this non bloody sacrifice but
it also bread and wine are also like the
right hand and the left hand I don't
know if you guys have seen my thoughts
about that this idea that regular food
you would call it and then ecstatic food
or or fermented food something like dead
then death turned against itself and
intoxication all that stuff can read
message book you've seen about that
so wiki's attic offers bread and one he
offers the the food and the intoxicated
offers the whole thing you know the
center of the margin he offers
everything and so Christ becomes and so
he becomes an image of Christ in that
sense that Christ is priest priest penis
comes from above the order of the
Levites because Christ was not a Levite
and so
prease leanness comes from the order of
melchizedek
that is an order which is above the
priest and the king who then which joins
them together and that is one of the
reasons why Christ offers bread and wine
but Christ doesn't just offer bread and
wine Christ Christ also offers blood and
and and flesh and so Christ is actually
above Melchizedek his what he offers
more than Melchizedek offers because he
offers he offers both that which the
priest and the King would offer but he
then he also offers with the nomads
offer he also offers the other side so
he you could call Melchizedek an image
of a risk of a possible restoration of
Cain of a restoration of the sacrifice
of Cain where Cain offers the fruit of
the land and is refused Abel offers that
the flock and is accepted alkies it
appears a strange figure and he's above
Abraham and he also offers the fruit of
the land and so it's a strange story its
moods it's really tough to think about
that and then Christ comes and does the
same he offers the you could call the
sacrifice of Cain but he also offers a
sacrifice of Abel at the same time
that's the craziness of communion it's
both at the same time so so hopefully
that answers that all right so Mike am i
right to say that Jacob doesn't
understand is not hearing the discussion
I may keep going and see if he answers
all right so next question so Connor
Magor asks Owen Benjen often speaks of
Wizardry for example for example using
words like racism anti-semitism and Nazi
have the effect of casting a spell on
the other hand there are ways that the
spells are broken my favorite is his
saying of people's motivations for
lollipops and fancy pants
which effectively unveils idols from
what they are I'd love to hear your
thoughts on wizardry and laughter
breaking the spells I'm still holding on
hope of YouTube getting in touch and him
coming to the church
I'd suggest leaving out some honey to
draw him in Plus milk and wine ah bears
like honey all right
so Connor Maggert um I haven't talked
about Owen Benjamin I guess since all of
this had kind of gone down you know like
I I don't really follow Owen Benjamin
I've watched I've watched a few of his
videos I kind of watched him go go after
Jordan Peterson I've seen him then turn
on Joe Rogan and then turn on a leaf
Jones and and then turn on I don't you
turn on steven crowder maybe now maybe
he did maybe not I don't know I I don't
totally follow him I kind of seen him in
the on the fringes and stuff so I don't
quite know what to think of him I'm not
sure I'm not sure what he's trying to do
and I'm not totally sure where he's
going is a good way to to say that I
think he I think he's I think
case scenario is that he wants to be a
real holy fool like that's the best-case
scenario best-case scenario is that he
is poking at everything
he's blowing everything up to show like
you said like like Connor like you noted
mention in your comments the fact that
we are we are let's say under
psychological spells you could say that
we that we that we have taboos that we
have things that that box us in that we
have things that that tell us what we're
allowed to say what we're allowed to
think and you don't realize that or were
not totally conscious of that and so
he's trying to to break that that's
maybe the best that's the best case I
don't want to go too far into what the
worst case scenario could be but let's
say just say this I think that I think
that it's very easy to point out other
people's wizardry and I understand why
why he see he does that and he sees it I
think he goes way too far I think that
he goes into the kind of conspiracy
theory that I really dislike which is
this you know this oh there's a there's
a there's a star in this movie with so
many so many points oh you know that's
Masonic this is Masonic it shows that
he's evil there you know and he has this
weird superficial vision of what
symbolism is where he's pointing out you
know details and in stories and movies
and he's showing how you know how this
is satanic that kind of stuff I really
read this like that a lot oh but let's
just so let's just let's just let's just
just look at for example the wizard
reading that that he engages in because
he also has his own wizardry and we all
have our own wizardry you know one of
the things he was doing for example when
he was talking when he was going out to
Durham Peterson I noticed is that he
would say things like
he would suggest that he knows things
that you don't know he would suggest
that he because he was on the inside
that somehow he knows he has the key he
can he knows things about Hollywood
about all these occult figures that you
don't know but he's not going to tell
you I could tell you stuff but I'm not
going to tell you you know trust me that
kind of that kind of of speaking and I
think that that that definitely is a
also a form of Wizarding now does join
Peterson engage in wizardry
yeah for sure everybody everybody
everybody who if you surprised anybody
using using language to influence they
will probably using some form something
that you could call a form of wizardry
now I agree I agree that social prestige
and money and all those things that it's
not I mean it's not a it's not please
mystery the idea that that money and
social prestige and our are things that
can affect your judgment and can prevent
you from saying things that you might
want to say that there's a that you can
be boxed in by that kind of of lollipop
and fancy pants as he says and and I
think that's something that should be
looked at to be thought about you know I
don't know if you guys watched the
interview between Milo and Jordan I
think that Milo did amazing you know I
think that I also think Gordon did
really well too but I think in this case
I think my oh man did amazing and I
think that he did point out that to the
fact that you know that certain things
that certain decisions that durin have
made show that he wants to stay in the
limelight that he wants to have he wants
to keep that attention and he doesn't
want to sacrifice it and so and and Milo
suggests that them like him like Owen
Benjamin like Alex Jones the people that
have been ban like Gavin McGinnis that
they they don't care about that
you don't care about the titles they
don't care about the procedure economy
rather they rather they they're there to
tell the truth or to be subversive or
whatever and you know fair enough fair
enough I think there's also there's also
a there's also something for being for
being to meet being let's a crafty has a
serpent and as innocent as a dove I
think there's something for that and
that you also have to be careful when
you're trying to get a message across
that you say it in a manner which will
not shut the ears of the people who you
want to speak to that they won't that
they won't stop listening to you as you
stop started speaking you can feel you
can give you a false sense of
self-satisfaction and make you think
that oh I am pure I am pure I just say
things the way they are you know I don't
I don't compromise I'm pure but
sometimes that can also be a form of
pride as well you know just as the just
as the other side could be a form of
greed you know and a form of desire to
please so you know everybody has their
wizardry all right so all right so Jacob
says what do you think this
multi-dimensional world's is saying
about the nature of reality
I like the kind of I guess what you mean
is the this the kind of like the
Spiderman multiverse type of
multi-dimensional world I don't think it
said I think it doesn't so much about
the nature of reality as much as it says
a lot about the nature where we are
today as a culture and how we are so
focused on multiplicity we're so focused
on the particular
that we even you know we were going
further than than this notion it's like
not only that we're focused on the world
of multiplicity in terms of how it
manifests itself in our world but we
want to go further into possibilities
imagine imagine that you know the the
ontological hierarchy and you have
identity in the center and you have
possibility in the edge you know and so
those two have to interact right and so
you have an identity but if if the
possibilities are limited it's going to
it's going to it's going to manifest
itself in those particularly think of a
tree right so you have a tree the tree
is planted in very few possibilities
let's say planted in a rocky area then
that tree will grow as a tree but it
will also it will maybe be smaller maybe
be more crooked maybe you know the roots
are going to be on the outside whereas
if the tree is planted in in that firm
the normal ground then the it will met
it will have more possibility in terms
of manifesting and so what we what's
happening in our world is that we've
moved very much away from possibility
from identity into possibility we we are
fascinated by possibility or fascinated
by the what if fascinated by the well
what about that and and you know why not
this as well you hear that when people
when people we try to let's say explain
the mystery of Christianity or try to
explain the path of Christianity and
someone all they can think of is asking
yeah but what about Judas and what about
the these obscure you know native
rituals that I don't know anything about
what about those okay okay like do they
leave can they save someone what about
them are they safe what about them and
it's like they're not they're not trying
they care more about what's possible
then what can be real in your life that
and so this idea that going all the way
out into now not only being obsessed
with possibility it's you
to be obsessed with extending that
possibility into other possibilities
that haven't even happened or that what
happened or that haven't happened you
know and so imagining that there are
infinite amounts of worlds that you know
manifest every single amount of every
different let's say path that something
could take at any moment of time is is
is is that obsession the obsession with
this this notion of possibility mmm and
in the end what it ends up being music
is a ends up being just a cheap version
of God you know because it's as if you
realize that at some point we need the
infinite there is that at some point if
you if you do enough cosmology and you
do enough observing of how the world
lays itself out you know you you need
the infinite and so in the end the
materialist will posit an infinite
universe and an absolute infinite
universe with all infinite possibilities
you know infinitely there as manifest
possibilities in a in an infinite
universe and you know that's that's the
materialist answer to God in the end you
know the answer that we give is that if
you now realize if you now come back and
you bring consciousness back into that
portrayal if you now do it understanding
that you are a person who is in the
world looking at the world then you have
to bring the personal back into your
infinite and you also have to see that
the personal as the the point in which
the infinite you know comes together
there's no other way because you don't
have another life besides your own and
that that also that changes that that
put the infinite in a different light
let's say makes
more akin to a person than just this
this massive you know just that's just a
quantifiable but infinitely quantifiable
you know lay out of the universe alright
hopefully that answers that let's see
let's go to the patreon questions okay
so Ryan Tinkham asks or when he comes
got a few questions
Ryan biscuit Pinkham ask he says hey
Jonathan I have so many questions for
you but let's start with two can you
explain what your ideal system of
society would be I've heard you say
you're more of a medievalist or
traditionalists can you explain what
that means to you specifically like are
you monarchist would you be in favor of
a king I feel like the more I look into
it and past the common misconception
about how every King was a tyrant I
start to feel like maybe it's actually
the proper structure for life also
it's you're in favor of a king one
absolute ruler then why do you reject
the Pope that is not a question in that
one question
well I'll to be totally honest with you
I really don't think that the solution
is political and I think I've said this
many times I I don't think that the
solution to the problem is political and
so I try not to go too much into the
political because to be honest I don't
know I don't know what what what the
best society would be like in the
context of our world right now
and so I think that the solution is
spiritual and I think that out of the
spiritual will calm down or will you
know that that the political system will
lay itself out from the basis of a a
spiritual
coming together so I think that that's
that's the way I see it now
I do I do think that the king you know I
would say that it I would say that that
just intuitively I would say that I I'm
a I believe in a form of aristocracy a
aristocracy of of not just it's not just
an aristocracy of title but I never
named in a form of aristocracy of a
skill you could say an aristocracy of
idea that that there could be that
people who deserve or are the smartest
or are they most have the most desire to
to care for those who are you know who
don't have the capacity to care for
themselves I think that you know the
kind of philosopher-king I hear that
that that Plato has I don't I think that
that maybe would be the old the best the
best version I do not I'm not an
absolute monarchist especially not today
I really would not like there to be an
absolute monarchy in our times and the
reason why is really is really the
problem of of Technology and that's just
reality is that in the Middle Ages a
king had let's say near absolutely power
you know but very limited range the King
had to depend on a air and air Socratic
system which would balance out the power
of the king and so the the the the King
had to somewhat pleased his aristocrats
or else at some point his aristocrats
would just kill him and the aristocrats
had to also somehow act justly towards
their the people who were under them his
their soldiers there are higher Knights
because those would also at some point
you know get rid of them as well and the
same goes down the idea that that that
lower orders you know don't revolt at
some point if you're not if you don't
treat them well means that you don't
know anything about history and the
revolution is not a sign here that that
the grumbling grumbling of the people
doesn't come up bubble up and start to
to throw off the the the people that are
above who are not doing what they should
be or who are who are problematic and
I'm not saying it justifies that I'm not
saying it's justified for the people to
come up and and start chopping head but
the idea that that that doesn't happen
his means you don't know about the nikah
revolt and you don't know about the 13th
century thirteen you know that the 13th
century France was a it was a crazy
crazy time you know and they were
peasant revolt and there was all this
stuff going on um and so the problem
today is that you could have a king who
would have absolute power and to
technology could control our lives
completely and so I think I'm very
difficult for a king an absolute monarch
today to not be a tyrant I think you're
just being almost impossible unless it
was Christ himself you know I don't
think it would be possible so so I don't
really know what the solution is I'm
sorry sorry I'm I'm disappointing you
and I think if you watch my videos
enough today for sure I would say that
for sure I'm not a Democrat in terms of
how I believe that decisions should or
are made I'm not I don't think that
democracy is is good in itself I think
there's a form of democracy that is
useful in the sense that I think there
should there needs to be a balance
between VD let's say that the leader who
proposes and the the people who say Amen
the people who say yes we're going to
follow you I think there needs to be a
balance in those two things and so I
think in that sense there needs to be
some democratic element where you know
the people had to say yes the people
have to - to manifest the will of the
king and they can't already they can't
just do it out of force because that
doesn't work it doesn't work there has
to be love between the king and the
people and that means that the king also
has to be attentive to the needs of the
people and the people have to say yes
you know but but yeah so enough about
that because seriously I'm gonna I'm
probably getting into trouble already by
talking about politics because I really
don't see that as the as the solution to
the problem so said why do you reject
the Pope I think that I think that's
when you know that's a really that's a
really good way to understand the
problem of let's say of a place where
the hierarchy kind of comes together the
the way that the ancient church saw the
the power of the Pope
okay so the Romans this is something
that people throw has had two visions of
let's say power they had what's called a
Tory test and potestas so so potestas
was power power in the military sense
power in the eye make things happen
I failed tell people what to do wait and
Tory toss was a kind of spiritual or
authority of of your position authority
of your in in Roman times with the
authority of your minions the authority
of your position in society in the fact
that you were wealthy the fact that you
had you had like this this globe when
influence there was like influence but
it was not legally binding right and so
the influence was like a it was really
like a kind of a spiritual influence
that you that you had people with
reverence you people would listen to you
people would
you know people would kind of would take
what you say seriously consider it you
know and and would think twice before
going against it and the way that the
the Orthodox Church is the way that went
became the Orthodox Church at that point
it wasn't viewed the Pope was as the
first among equal as the one who had the
most Ettore toss but they did not do the
Pope as having absolute potestas they
then do the Pope as as being the one who
can decide who's the priest in in in you
know parish or the Pope can decide who's
the bishop in some little town in Nicaea
the Pope had a Tory test but then the
potestas was the potestas was what would
come down into the into the local area
to the point where it's the Bishop of a
city who had the potatoes so each Bishop
of each city had the right the power to
to name their own their own priests you
know and so and if there was a hierarchy
above the bishop
that Bishop it became a kind of
hierarchy of over Tory ties a hierarchy
of reverence I hired here so the problem
happens when the pulp starts to act like
a like a legal and someone who has legal
and legal power over the church's you
know in in the Catholic Church the Pope
can call back any priest the probe can
call back any bishop the boat can
replace any priest can replace
individual the ship the Pope has
absolute power in terms of the Catholic
Church and that is just was never the
way that the Orthodox perceived it and
and I think that's also not the right
way for a hierarchy to exist you know I
think that a normal hierarchy acts that
the normal hierarchy lets the
or rungs of the hierarchy had their own
exists at their own level and have their
own power at their own level and that
they they they you know I mean I say
that because in a military obviously
it's not like that in the military you
know but that's that's really how the
Christian hierarchy was seen by the
other and so I don't the the the
Orthodox even the Orthodox today they
always know that there was that that st.
Peter had privacy but it was seen as a
primacy of a Torah toss and and so and
so when Peter started saying you know
when Peter started saying that that he
would not never never deny Christ if he
would never think it's impossible for
Peter to deny Christ said that he is
without any fault then I think just like
st. Peter I think I think the Pope has
the strengths and the weaknesses of st.
Peter say it that way all right
okay so Brian Pinkham also asks you seem
not to like the worship of the
individual we have today but doesn't
that come from Christianity the notion
that everyone is special because they
are made in the image of God so what is
the proper balance of the individual and
the collective now I think this is a
good question right I think it's a good
question because I think you can help us
to understand the difference between
what the modern person called the
individual and what the ancients would
have called the hypostasis
or the person those two are not the same
the individual as we understand it today
is the accumulation of your thoughts and
your will and your emotions and your
desires now
that is not how that is not how the
person was seen in the Christian
tradition
you know if you read the ascetic fathers
if you read the the church fathers it
will literally say things like you're
not your thoughts are not your will you
are not your desires you are not those
things right you are that is the you
that the highest version of you is
beyond that you know and it actually
comes right up to the idea that the
higher version of you is actually God in
you which is the image of God in you is
the place where you know it's the heart
it's the place where everything comes
together but also transcends all those
other things it's not that your thoughts
don't participate in you it's not that
that your desires aren't a part of you
but they they have to lead up to
something which transcends those those
particulars you would say and so the
problem is that if we look at the
worship of the individual that we have
today we are usually looking at is their
personality you know it is their their
their personality their their capacity
to succeed in the world to make money to
be famous to to be funny to be you know
to have accomplished this wrote some
great novel or doing that and that
really is not at all Christian right if
you look at for example you have you
have the right version of that in the
veneration of the saints now if you look
at the veneration of the Saints what we
have is the veneration of the person's
because we venerate the saints to the
extent that they resemble Christ and
that they manifest Christ in a specific
instance you know in a particular
context that's their personhood like
that that's the highest form and so and
so although some people might think that
it looks like the way that we talk about
individuality today it actually is not
because the really the veneration of the
Saints has to do with the manner in
which those people those people are
connected to Christ rather than the
manner in which those people stand out
and
are individuals which stand out next to
the others the reason why they stand out
next to the others in to the extent in
which they manifest the divine logos and
so yeah that's that that's very
different and so what is the proper
balance of the individual and the
collective in the notion of the the
Christian notion of the person you
actually see that because the the human
person is seen as a hypothesis of human
nature is seen as a particular instance
instance of human nature and so the idea
is that as you will manifest Christ you
actually also end up manifesting the
highest form of what the human nature is
and and so you could say that your goal
is to be the most human you can be in
the sense that as you manifest Christ in
the world we're also manifesting the
fullness of humanity in your particular
instance right so it's very different
and and because we are instance
instantiations of human nature as we
manifest that human nature and as we
manifest Christ you realize that you are
nothing without communion a person is a
communal being that is what we are so
one of the aspects of being a person is
being in communion with the collective
you call but the collector is not the
right word you know the the communion of
the saints you know the gathering in of
the saints is a better way to see it and
so as we gather as we approach the the
fullness of human nature as we also
approach Christ
then we also come closer to each other
and the more you become a person the
more you are one with your neighbor the
more you love your neighbor the more you
are connected to the people around you
and so those two things are actually not
opposites at all they're they're they
actually come together as you as you are
becoming fully a person you also become
fully in community with others
you know yeah exactly to a point where
all you see and others is I mean this is
the Saints version now I not there
obviously but to a point where when you
see others when you look at others all
you see in them is Christ in them you
see them as these lights which manifests
Christ even beyond their own foibles
even ground their own sins you end up in
a place where everything you see
everything as this communion which is
which is you know extended from Christ
and coming back to Christ all right hope
that's hope that's answering I know why
I'm the tonight is like mystical knife
some reason I just keep using very
mystical language hopefully I'm not
freaking everybody out all right okay so
now I'm got a series of questions from
norm holding so I think I understand how
God is good or benevolent but what I am
still struggling with is why does he
need us
why have us around to argue that he is
good and that he wants to share
existence for its own sake seems to be a
bit cheap or circular or at least in how
I'm conceptual conceptualizing it or
understanding it wow so you guys are
really pushing me in the mystical stuff
here guys this is probably should we
talk about this as usual so okay so a
way to see it a way to see it it would
be this way to see it would be this is
that God is infinite okay God is is is
the infinite and so in order
for the infinite to the infinite there's
also this is kind of you could say
ecstatic element to the divine which is
that the divine also the divine goes
outside of itself without going outside
of itself because there is no outside
but it's like a restraint contradiction
where the divine goes outside of itself
without going outside of itself and in
that going outside of itself without
going outside of itself that is what you
would say creation is it's a creation is
is God
you know radiating out on his of his of
the Trinity radiating out but then also
being but still being within God okay
this is stuff all right stuff to talk
about
sorry and so the way that the Orthodox
will talk about that is this notion that
of the divine energies right that that
that God's will is God himself and that
hiding underneath all of creation is is
is also God and so you could see you
could see the whole thing the whole
pattern is the massive massive cosmic
infinite whatever pattern as a kind of
breathing great breathing out and
breathing in you know that the divine in
its infinite in its infinite we
creating capacity you know it's like it
is breathing out and God got out pours
out of himself but without never
actually leaving himself and that that
you know and that his will and that
would be a way to describe that's a
creation but then it all comes back into
into God ultimately and I know that
that's problematic because obviously
that the the you know the the church
fathers both talk about a protest assist
this idea of the final restoration and
also talk against it in in several in
some of the church councils and some of
the fathers I think the way is to try to
properly understand it there are ways to
try to figure out how you know that that
this is real that everything is brought
in to God that everything must return to
God but that there there always is that
possibility of that outside Ness
manifesting itself you know the the gain
of the the you know the the fire all
that stuff the idea that there is always
the possibility of refusing to
participate in that and that's also ends
up being part of the in of the infinite
you know that the particulars you know
the God's creation of particulars and
man especially has the possibility even
though everything will return to God has
the possibility of nonetheless not
participating in that return even though
they ultimately will and sometimes
that's shown is the idea that that you
know that let's say like the return of
all things into God will manifest itself
for some as a deifying fire and for
those for others as a as a burning
judgment you know and so it's like these
questions are too big you know they're
really huge and so it's very difficult
to answer them without using this
strange language that I've just used and
so a simple simple
a simple way of under of bantering that
a way that I think is is maybe more
grounded in terms of how people have
talked about before is that God is love
and that God is God is love that is I've
said this again is that the infinite is
both one and many and that God is one
and many and and that that mode of being
you know the mode of being in love of
love as being one and many
simultaneously in and ultimately it it
also the fact that love is the mode of
being of everything and that is the only
being of God that the more being that we
can share with God that in also
necessarily you could say necessarily
move out of God like I said without
moving into God visit love can't be
completely full if it's just self
contained you would say because it yeah
and so then we are called creation and
it is called to participate in God you
know through love by you know by by part
it by no participating in the morning
being that God has and by doing that we
are actually the media fide you know we
are actually becoming becoming God to
the extent that that's possible so Rama
gives a precision discretion he says he
needs us to be one in many at the same
time then yes yeah of course that's what
communion is that's what the church is
that's what that's what you are that's
what everything is everything is all
winning many there's there's that's the
waiting so that's way for things to
exist there's no there's no other way
for things to exist besides being one in
many adjoining of one in many
yeah anyways that's the way I see it I
know arm cold a says in the end game of
evangelization the eradication of all
other religions and even denomination
and christianity say so that only Roman
Catholics exist for existence I don't
know is that maybe that's the that the
end game of some people who do that
realization I think the end game of
evangelization in terms of I think that
I think okay how about this is gonna I'm
gonna stay right up in there the
mystical stuff today I'm gonna just
freak everybody out I would say that I
would say the end game of evangelization
is that Christ cosmically accomplishes
what he accomplished in the tomb say it
that way that as Christ went into death
and reached the bottom of the
ontological bottom of a reality and then
brought it all to the Father so to
Christianity must reach the ends of the
world must reach the end of history in
order to in order to connect everything
to Christ I don't necessarily think that
that means that all other religions will
be eliminated or denominations I think
that we do have this image of
eschatological return to unity that is
in the eschaton in this moment which is
the moment of moments you know when
Christ returns like a lightning like
lightning from east to west you know and
fills the universe with his glory I
think that then yes there will be
unity and multiplicity imbalance and so
and so so yeah yeah all right all right
no you're asking hard questions your
buddy okay here we go
so norm gonna ask again you're talking
media pundits you spoke about the
Superman story and the idea of an orb
being dropped in the water with the
waves rippling out you spoke about
returning to the center is the only
option after everything has been turned
upside down or reboot so to speak you
describe this orb as jbp does of
rescuing your father from the belly of
the whale in your own words a return of
the logos I wonder though would it be
fair to describe this or instead as God
as a return to the origin but maybe this
is what you meant by logos anyways so I
I think that I mean I think that you
could say that I think you could say I
think that is the logos and I think the
logos is divine I think that ultimately
it's hard because the orbit the orb is
this is a is a is a is a ball it's a
center it's a pearl it's a precious
thing you know it's also the locust of
action it's all that and then you know
you could say that you know the ball
inside the ball inside the ball inside
the ball right there
this invisible spark inside it is God
himself like his divine spark but got to
be careful because we usually don't we
usually don't have access to that direct
we have access to veiled versions of it
we have access to secondary versions you
could say of The effect of that divine
spark which is hiding in the world and
so um so yes
return to the origin but that doesn't
that that won't necessarily always
manifest itself as you know as God
directly so for example you know finding
the finding the the golden ball has been
dropped in the water could be you
learning - it could be you learning to
respect your father your own actual
earthly father learn to reverence your
own father
despite his whole despite his problems
learn to see yourself as being
ontologically dependent on him and
having reverence for your your father in
the world you know discovering the orb
you know can also be um you know
focusing on truth and and and going down
into the chaos and finding those things
that are true and pulling them out of
the water so that you can then act in a
straight manner finding the golden ball
can also be you know discovering the
thing that holds any group together you
know you have a team and the team is
falling apart and everybody's doing
their own thing and everybody is is is
acting without considering the others
and then finding the golden ball could
be going in and rediscovering the
purpose of why that team existed in the
first place being able to embody that
and and communicate that to the others
of the team so so so this structure is a
is a is a structure and it manifests
itself at all different levels and then
ultimately like in the middle of the
middle of the middle of the middle yes
you're right that is ultimately the
divine spark but like I said be careful
we don't have access to that most of the
time most of the time we are dealing
with secondary layers all right I hope
that makes sense
all right so norm asked one last
question ask me if I've read Cormac
McCarthy's the Sunset Limited and no I
have not read that so mark Peters asked
me hello Jonathan
you and your family are in my prayers
what did you mean when you said the
Eastern Orthodoxy Thomas Aquinas as a
pivotal figure leading to the synthesis
hmm maybe I have the term wrong but I
got the sense that he rip it in
something that further divided the
eastern and the Western Church maybe I
misinterpreted something I don't think
that I never used the word synthesis to
talk about Thomas Aquinas um I don't
know enough about Aquinas
I've heard people tell me that he's
really to blame and others people tell
me that he's not totally to blame that
later on in the development of his
thought and and of Thomism that later
people are to blame but for sure
the 12th century is a key is a key
moment in the history of the church you
know as Eastern Orthodox it's kind of
easy maybe too easy to see that that the
schism happens and then after not very
long afterwards you see people like
akhom Aquinas and Duns Scotus
and people who start to pull apart
incarnation of thinking would be the
best way to understand it to either make
God too high up in the separate God from
the world so much that he becomes that
like an alien figure you see that in
Arkham and then in someone told me that
it's not actually there and done SCOTUS
but that that in these followers later I
don't know this idea that God is
actually
somehow inside the system you know that
that this is the scientific way of
seeing God it's like like God is some
being inside the system whoo-hoo somehow
we hear weird people say things like
well God created world he was limited he
was limited by this and this and limited
by this and this and it's like God is
not in the system folks you can't you
can try to find him in the system that's
true kidding it all wrong God is is
beyond the system the whole system the
entire system everything you say never
in all of it all of all the structures
all the manifestations and everything
got to be on that but he's also the
source of everything and I see to me
that is where the synthesis starts to
break apart is when you stop to have a
have an idea that God is both completely
transcendent and and beyond all category
but then he's also at the same time the
source of everything and is also behind
hidden behind everything and without
without that the infinite you know the
world doesn't exist maybe hopefully that
answers all right so Jonathan do you
have any bibliographical resources you
can share on ancients of all the Klang
which I learned you where there's books
but I don't know where hardly any of you
is this material is coming from I read
San Ephraim Syrians reflections of the
book of Genesis and st. Gregory of
nYSSA's life of Moses well I'd say
you're doing pretty well you know
there's a great book like in terms of
visual imagery I think there's a there's
a great book that's out there by
vladimir lossky and called them the
meaning of icons i think it's a it's a
very good book and it can help you to
understand this stuff I think that I
mean I would say look at my website I
have a reading list on my website of
books that deal with symbolism there are
some modern authors I think are helpful
but you have to be careful with them
that's why I tend not to quote them too
much and I also tend not to refer
them because I do think that we have
there's enough if you would do the work
if you do the work of seeing the
patterns there's quite a bit in Saint
Ephrem and st. Gregory st. Maximus as
well to help you I'm not saying it's
easy but I but I think that it's there
but I I have at some times told eagle
that that it might you know you can read
mercy a Leon's work in terms of a modern
person it can maybe help you understand
some symbolism um some people say that
it's that you should write I don't read
young but if reading young is going to
at least I hope you get a sense of
symbolic analogies and symbolic
structures you know I'm fine you can
read some but there's also even I think
some of the post pardon it's like I told
I've said this before reading Jacques
Derrida and was the other book when I'm
back yeah as a young and in my 20s you
know that helped me to understand
symbolism because they come out they
come from it upside down but you know if
you're aware that they're upside down
then you can still see that they're
noticing the patterns and noticing the
patterns but they're just doing it from
an upside out place you know I've seen
that too like I've had some things
bye-bye Freud for example where I
thought man he gets it he totally gets
it it's just that instead of seeing how
sexuality is a is a pattern which is
analogical to the pattern of being
itself he rather sees all the patterns
of human existence pointing downwards
towards you know sexual desire but then
the problem happens again it's like then
where does that sexual desire come from
like why is it that we have these sexual
desire and why is it that the world is
made that way you know
then it flipped back on itself because
it has to that it necessarily has to
manifest a larger pattern of reality or
else it wouldn't exist and so so I've
I've read people like that you know I
mentioned in my reading list that
it can be helpful to read to read vene
veno
who is a French traditionalist but you
have to be careful with him he says a
lot of weird stuff he would he also
became a Muslim he became a Sufi and he
also I think he misunderstood some
aspects of Christianity but in terms of
symbolic intuition he definitely is one
of the best in the 20th century and he
couldn't he he also he also communicates
it in a language which I think people
can be can understand and so his book
reign of quantity is a is a really good
book and there's also the the sacred
symbols of was it called symbols of
sacred science or something but I
haven't read those books in a very long
time since my 20s because I feel like I
have enough I find enough in in the
Bible and in the father's and in reading
also extra biblical traditions to kind
of help you see things that you didn't
see when you read though the Bible
itself slowly that helps but I have a
reading list guys you can check it out
on my website right 2 Corinthians 3 also
drew McMahon asks in 2 Corinthians 13:5
the Apostle Paul has the Corinthian
believers or do not realize about
yourselves that Jesus Christ is in you
this question of whether we are
searching for something beyond ourselves
or within ourselves continuously pops
into my mind and I'm wondering your
thoughts thanks so I think I kind of
answered that question in the sense that
the christ is in you of course Christ is
in you if Christ wasn't in you you would
exist the divine logos is hidden in all
things the divine logos is hidding is
hidden is behind is is the divine is it
is a divine essence it the divine
essences in the world participate the
lowly participate in
are gathered into Christ and so you can
see it as fact that all the essences all
the reasons for things in the world are
gathered into the divine reason that the
divine logos the divine purpose right
but that you can also see it as Christ
is also hidden in every single thing in
every single you know manifestation in
the world Christ is hidden inside that
and especially in the human person
because the human person is the place in
the in the world where all things gather
together through our our mind to our
soul to our consciousness right we
talked about this before someone fun
that we play a particular role in being
capable of a perceiving meaning and an
end of participating in how the world
has meaning and so so yes so you could
say that
it is it is beyond yourself if you think
of yourself as just an individual like
we said before so Christ in you is
definitely beyond you you know saying
that st. Isaac Assyrian talks about how
he says you know enter the chamber of
your heart and there you will find the
celestial chamber right and there you
will find the ladder by which you need
to ascend in order to encounter God and
so it's like the movement that you need
that you're doing is an inward movement
into yourself as you are saying where
the reason pops about removing the
garments of skin removing the garments
removing this extra extra texture aeneas
things you're you know moving away from
your thoughts we've been away from your
desires not identifying with them is the
way to see it not identifying with your
thoughts your desires your will all of
that moving inwards and and entering
into the heart as the hesychast say and
then you find
you know ultimately you find Christ in
you but that doesn't mean that you're a
Christ that's very important
does it mean that you you know Drew or
Jonathan that I am Christ now is that
what it means it means that Christ is
that which makes me exist and is that
which which to which ultimately I am
attached right all right man this talk
guys
seriously what is going on with all the
mystical stuff all right here we go
so last question so from Tyson and
Jessica Gabe in two icons at our church
one of the mystical supper the other of
the hospitality of a ram there is a
small dark rectangular hole depicted on
the side of the table in each image what
is the significance of this we see I did
probably have to think about it because
the be honest I've never actually
thought about it although now that you
say so I have noticed that that is
something which does appear sometimes
but not always
so to be honest I would have to think
about it and I also have to reach or we
research it a little bit because I'm not
sure that that's what's necessarily
going on you know it's tough because
it's not because something exists that
necessarily is what we want it to be but
I let me think about it
I mean is it there in rube limbs I can't
yes it is their lives icon so if it's
their room labs icon I would think that
it probably does have something so let
me think about it because you've you you
now you oh now you definitely piqued my
kick and someone points out something in
icons that I've never noticed before you
definitely got my curiosity going so so
thank you for that and I will think
about it and hopefully maybe at the next
Q&A I can tell you if I if I think that
it did then I've come to some conclusion
you could say all right guys so nearly
10:30 once again I want to first of all
again I want to thank everybody so many
people have I've come to to our help so
many people have been sending money to
to PayPal or through the GoFundMe
campaign it has been it has been
overwhelmingly touching I mean I I get
emotional just thinking about you know
all these people kind of coming coming
to help us so so all I can say is thank
you so much my family is so grateful to
all of you who have been helping us we
you know you don't have to worry so much
in terms of the in terms of the material
stuff right now like we don't have to
worry about that thinking the chaos is
still there like to get our lives back
together and to to know what's going to
happen with our house because we still
don't know whether or not we'll be able
to rebuild or not or whatever we don't
know yet but
but for sure like I I'm not worried
right now because I mean I should be
worried because God is in charge but I
think God is showing me these in charge
you know by all of you stepping up and
helping us through this tough time and
it's been amazing to like it here is he
one of the most one of the things that
you know when I think about it I'm gonna
have to stop myself from from tearing up
but you know people knew that I lost my
library and so and so people started
giving me books and I asked people to
sign the books because you know it's so
crazy to think that now someone I forget
his name it's horrible I should remember
his name but uh but someone at at at the
conference just now in Louisiana gave me
a copy of Saint Ephrem his book Mike my
conference was based on say nephrons
book and I'd lost it and so I'm online I
posted cuz I was desperate online I I
had to prepare my confidence and I just
hadn't even realized that I didn't have
a book anymore there's wait wait I had a
reading like in two days I I didn't have
time to get it from Amazon or whatever
so I asked people like can you find a
PDF for me and then some people found a
p.m. and then someone someone then
brought the book - too easy Anna and
that and then everybody's name in it and
so now I have some books where when I
read them in the future
I always have this memory of yeah of all
these people around me that kind of
stepped up and and and surrounded us
with with love and care and support so
thanks a lot guys and yeah I will see
you all in a month again right bye bye